speaking of hate
Okay okay something you want to say
Chris Los Angeles oh I've finally been
to the City of Lights whoever it's
called Angel City I've had the city of
disappointment and lots of [__]
traffic and awful actually the food's
good and the people are good I'll get I
think the people of LA are really
friendly very nice I don't know why
everyone's so surprised it's a little
bit worrying you guys have been there a
lot more than I have I mean I think that
I think a lot of I guess people I
interact with are pretty nice but I get
a very sterilized view of it I suppose
yeah I I mean I like the people that I
know that I mean the content creators
but the general Vibe I get of La is that
it's uh every man for themselves it's
very superficial a lot of ways in and
out burger yeah
I'm out of people like you have to get
the In and Out Burger dude it's amazing
I went there and I got the french fries
no the french fries are [__] right yeah
and then they tasted like cardboard
tastes like something yeah they have a
Bookshop and like I was like what is
this a lot of people praise the chips
they're like you you got the wrong fries
dude they're animalistic [__]
ridiculous fries
what I I you know when you go to [__]
burger restaurant you just want fries I
don't want like the secret special order
well yeah I think because the fries are
just so bad what's the What's it gonna
be animals animals but the the reason
why I guess it's it's kind of revered is
that it's like you can get the double
burger for like what five bucks so it's
like a really good price for a solid
body yeah because like you you know
obviously it's not as good as like five
guys but Five Guys is like every time
surprise I mean Five Guys is basically
restaurant prices they charge a
ridiculous amount and they're those
fries those Cajun Friesian fries man
yeah good yeah it was a really trippy
City when I did the chess boxing I
stayed in downtown L.A and it is a bit
you know it is a bit like mad
Maxi after you know a long 12 hour
flight whatever it is and like yeah
there was
just a man running naked down the middle
of the road going and I was like yep
hello yeah yeah sounds about right Skid
Row uh near it I was staying I think two
or three blocks of it oh God you know
that's right that's that's right
yeah there's definitely a lot of issues
going on there but but um yeah I know
God's been wanting to grill me on the
chess boxing can we see a cliff have
gone like I was so disappointed in Chris
I feel like I let you down gone you you
didn't let me down I was it I you know I
got tilted for you you know you know we
you know I was tuning into the chess
boxing to cheer on my bro cheer on my
man and you were doing so well you had
this point where you're about to win and
then you had a point where you could
have like checkmated or ended the game
and then you threw away your queen
it's literally the worst mistake you
literally you literally went from a
winning position to uh throwing away
your queen and I was just like what the
[__] up yeah this is really annoying in
the chess boxing fight like the the the
real-time chessboard that all the
viewers Everyone's Watching is kind of
broken yeah yeah we'll see what I was
doing a little bit behind I was the
first two rounds I was doing really well
like I pinned the queen yeah and I was
being really fast and my tactic was to
try and move really quickly and get like
a minute ahead yeah by the second round
of Chess that's where I was at but like
I sort of shot myself with the foot
because every one who I told that I was
doing the boxing stuff they were like
everyone has a plan do they get punched
in the face I was like [__] off I think
I know what I'm doing and then I got hit
in the face very hard on the on the
second round I got hit in the face and
have you ever been hit in the face yeah
yeah you probably have yeah
your brothers yeah I have actually yeah
huh where uh at a house party when I was
uh 18 years old yeah I just I got just
got in a fight uh with uh someone was
like really really [__] drunk and
just looking for a fight uh
group of them started on a few mates of
mine uh and then one of them threw a
punch and then just a fight in suit and
that's the only fight I've ever been a
part of and uh yeah that's good that's
good yeah how did it feel would you
enjoy it didn't it feel great
yeah
actually after that I was like you know
what maybe being a monk is a bad thing I
have no enemies actually
this is overrated
uh but yeah that was like I remember the
first time getting punched and like
getting probably punched in the face and
this was like not even in a controlled
environment this was just straight up
just getting punched in the face uh you
you have that you know I had the moment
like you you basically get stun locked
you're just like you feel it and then
you don't feel the pain you just feel
like the shock of it happening too yeah
you got the adrenaline rush and you just
I just remember being punching the face
and I just like hold holy [__] what the
[__] just happened it's like it's like
the flashbanging code yeah yeah exactly
you just like stun looks I I I know I
never forgot that feeling of like being
punched for the first time because you
just like you know you you forget like
what just happened you're like oh I just
got punch in the face yeah I think you
start punching back I mean it only
happened to me when I was 14. but I was
making fun of some guy's bike it was the
most mundane fight some guy turned up
who I hated I need a bike called a
mongoose prey and I was like mate your
bike's [__] I was like what did you say
like Mongoose and he punched me that was
the only fight I had had pre 30 years
old
and so I yeah I when I
buy some shoes
yeah that Mongoose Pro bike what a
balance Mongoose prayer side uh yeah so
I signed up the chess boxing because
Conor made me do it
I never I said you wouldn't do it
was like yeah you want to do it bro I
was like yeah right and that was the
main reason just to spike on and also
part of the fitness
chairs
yeah and honestly like the boxing
training was relentless and great but I
I was training with Nick and I you've
met Nick you guys learning he's uh he he
was in the boxing rig he's kind of like
oh okay okay oh yeah he's a former K1
kickboxing champion right of Japan he
fought like in the in the Tokyo dome in
the early 2000s and it was watched by
like 50 million people yeah he's a real
celebrity in Japan but he is like Gaston
out of the enemies in the Beast his arms
are like without the baggage
he's like a thousand eggs a day his arms
are like the size of Spain they are and
they're massive and if he hits you as he
did training like we so I would spy with
him a few times a week
um and he hit me in the face and like
everything just sort of went white for a
second it was a really scary yeah it was
[__] scary because I've never been
I've never had that before and it wasn't
even a big hit by his standards but
again when he's super trained to do this
yeah
okay I'm gonna hit you now you're ready
I was like yeah I'm ready
I was like whoa I'm actually quite
scared now it's like you know when you
get hit like that your whole brain sort
of rocks a little bit yeah this white
flash which is something I'd never
experienced before right I've never had
that white flash
concussion
I so I'd never had that and I was like
oh what the [__] have I done at this
point it was like November
did you want to like it was probably I
didn't back out but I was like has maybe
this was a bad decision
having no actual experience yeah but I
was against that German dude I can't
remember his name yeah
and then while he was training and I I
always thought I could take him he was a
bit taller than me it was quite skinny
yeah um and I think we would have been
on par with chess or maybe he would have
been a little bit better on chess but
then he burst his eardrum train yeah
somebody hit him in the air here got
blown up and he was like I can't fight
now yeah
um who I was going against and here to
pull out for other health reasons so
it's just like God doesn't want me to
fight I think it's pretty common though
that a lot of these these events are
like 50 of the fighters or not a little
less than that but end up pulling out
for concussion yeah whatever it is just
because yeah and there was a video up to
that one like yeah there's a lot of
people who pulled out and uh so I was
like oh maybe God let me off the hook
here and then like don't worry we've
brought in a black belt in Jiu Jitsu I
was like brilliant
[Music]
when you came out I saw after the fact
but because obviously I was up there
with you but everyone was like rip rip
Chris did you see the twitch shot replay
at all I yeah I did watch it back so I
came out with um uh Nick competing
Connor were cheering and I was like yeah
you know I was like hey it's like
[__] 50 000 people there 500 000
watches online it was really cool moment
actually that was like the highlight of
like last year for me yeah look at that
walkout and then I I was really cocky I
was like I got a box of Hershey's and
smashed it over my leg and threw it into
the crown and then he can he comes out
to some like [__] terrifying
soundtrack from like a horror film so
like sirens and then I yeah I saw that
it was a poll and it was like is Chris
gonna die
he's obviously someone who had uh you
know worked out and had Fitness as a
huge part of his life yeah yeah so
obviously you know as for me as a viewer
watching it with twitch chat like like
there were a lot of abroad and Japan
fans in chat cheering you on you came
out first and everyone's like yo
everyone's like being supportive the
hope was high yeah it's like you got it
and then there was just like one [__]
shot of your opponent walking out and I
think that was just a collective oh [__]
oh [__] well it's been a good run boys
get the body bag ready
I like we were actually a similar way he
was he's a bit taller and he had big
arms but because my legs are like tree
trunks you know my muscles in my legs
which is not overly useful I'm fast as
[__] boy
different thing yeah but uh yeah but I
was still like
yeah and then we had the chess match the
first round and it was going really well
I was I was really up on time which is
my strategy I was like if I [__] my
queen which I actually thought I might
under stress at least I'd be like a
minute up right yeah and then I went to
the first match and he and it's just
really weird it's really hard to explain
what it's like being in a ring with 20
000 people whatever it was around but
like you you forget they're all there
because the bright lights are on your
face and all you can see is him and in
between you can sort of see in the
distance Conor and the audience going
because I can see every shoulder but
like yeah just this moment where I saw
him like focusing on me about to hit me
and I was like what the [__] have I done
what is this like I really stitched
myself up my past self really [__] me
like when you when you're looking at
someone you're like I'm about to get hit
in front of like half a million people
yeah like that's what it's like what
have I done like the moments later cocky
[__] her she's throwing it into the
crowd and now it's like I could like get
knocked out or die in front of everyone
you think you're just not like uh was
that like a weird thing for you to have
to do to like lock on to someone and be
like I gotta punch this guy yeah because
when I was training with Nick we didn't
really Spa properly yeah we were hitting
each other but I never had a and this is
my fault I didn't put enough time into
it I really didn't train that much with
the boxing as much as I should have yeah
trained on the fitness front right for
stamina yeah and I suppose that's one
good thing in the chess box I survived I
made it to round three yeah it takes so
much energy to keep moving and dodging
and blocking throwing punches and um but
I had never fought anyone before really
and I couldn't fight Nick because he was
too big and I could not have won so that
was really my first actual fight
sparring practice or not yeah it was a
spectacular error a lot of the other uh
YouTubers whatever that did it that I
really went for it that I had at least
enjoyed it and really liked it were like
yeah sparring was everything like if
they they would use Mark so much and
that really allowed them to kind of get
a lot better at boxing and I think being
like you mentioned just had been
prepared to be beaten up yeah it seems
like a hard thing to do and uh you know
that's why a lot of people get injured
yeah
but I'm the sort of person that's always
like oh I do the homework tomorrow
in that first match when he locked on
and he got that first punch I got really
stunned yeah and I was like oh my God
you look like when he landed the first
hit on you that you were like oh [__]
I'm gonna I gotta figure something out
yeah yeah and the plan was basically
trying to keep avoiding or blocking yeah
I mean honestly a legitimate strategy if
you know you're not gonna be able to
outbox him yeah I didn't think I could
outbox yeah I mean he clearly had
experience but so the second round of
Chess I started moving up and I actually
had a plan of attack blocked his queen
and I was like oh he's King rather and I
was like I could actually win this wrap
this up in the second round right and
then it got to the end of the second
round and I was two three moves away
from executing the plan and then time
was up and I was like No And then I went
back in the battlefield completely
obliterated and punched in the face over
and over and by the time I came back I
was like oh because your heart's going
like yeah
if your head's a bit like and like I
sort of just went uh that one there and
I [__] did the wrong one
but I guess that's the difficulty yeah
that's just boxing right so you have to
manage all that stress level yeah but if
you watch it luckily I don't go
oh because I still felt like I might be
able to win because I looked at the
timer and there was a minute up and it's
another thing that's really weird you're
wearing the headphones right yeah so you
can't hear they don't really help that
much they don't help you're listening to
[__] Beethoven while you're having a
stroke because it's like I'm having a
heart attack a stroker listening to
Beethoven all at once while playing
chess and getting beaten up when I was
wearing them I could easily hear the
crowd exactly and I could hear like the
moment I [__]
before he even retaliated I think
everyone went
and I was like no but and then in the
third round I got really angry and went
a bit aggressive but yeah I I think the
thing with the chest boxing I feel like
I didn't deserve to win after I
blundered the queen maybe it's the wrong
way of looking at it I did win after all
um and there were some major mistakes
like the chessboard was set up wrong
when I started yeah I was like and go
and I was like and I moved and I I think
I [__] up I made like an illegal move
because the horse was in the wrong
Square the horse and the bishop were in
the wrong [__] place
and then he started making some illegal
moves and it all went to [__] a little
bit but yeah it was It was kind of weird
because then I guess the illegal move
allowed them to have time to kind of
think and then yeah it was really
bizarre it was yeah I guess they just
didn't expect the chess level to be that
bad where people would just be making
illegal moves yeah
yeah I mean you kept you cool after you
blundered the queen yeah yeah that's
that's the important thing in chess I
guess did you do any chess practice I
did do a fair bit of Chess yeah okay it
was cool actually I was like one day
I'll be training boxing training yeah uh
at my friend's gym over in like a Yorkie
Parker and then the next day I'll be
like in New York park with the chest
train and we playing in the Parker stuff
it was a really cool time actually my
week was kind of like spread between
chess and boxing and then writing a book
and it was really really weird kind of
three four months which is why like no
videos can't train to not blunder though
yeah yeah
at every level as well like even like
the grand Masters sometimes blunder
pieces well in the last week before
training when I was doing chess they
made me like run for like 30 seconds
really intense then sit down and play oh
my God it changes the game oh I can
imagine yeah you know when your heart's
racing yeah yeah really good experience
don't regret doing it we'll look back on
it and go wow but I don't think I want
to get hit in the face again no more
boxes you're going out as a champ yeah
yeah
The Undefeated Champion the chess boxing
champion why not you know but I I think
I might carry on the boxing training
without them
so I actually felt like I could defend
myself in a way that I never could
perform before last year yeah you know
was it like in the dressing room
beforehand were you like nervous uh yeah
when did it like hit you it hit me
there's the Stadium's there right right
and we had a suite or a room upstairs
and you were there in a few yeah in the
big room with Ludwig in the team I came
in and out every night
that's because Chris was in like the
zone and Nick was like I was talking to
you like you're about to [__] go on a
Navy Seals raid and they were so in the
zone that I was like I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna let him do the thing yeah
yeah because Nick was like don't you
[__] dare talk to him don't you dare
talk be nice too and I was like
I don't think enough space to talk to
your opponent I get it I get it because
I guess if it's more like you don't even
want to have an ounce of sympathy when
you're trying to punch the game yeah of
course but also at the end of the day I
was like I think it's just a fun little
walk sugar well that was a weird thing
actually because I did talk to my
opponent um over at flow PJ beforehand
and like he humanized him a bit I saw
he's a real American person and I was
like so when I'm fighting him I'm like I
don't actually dislike this guy why do I
have to hit him
he's like [__] like that down there
like it's really weird you know he's
like I am going to kill this man yeah
but hit me when I was in that room
looking down right I did have like a
small like Panic attacking moment I was
like what the [__] have I done why would
you do this yourself it's like you know
going oh yeah I'll put my feet in a
blender no problem and then like the day
arrives the blender's there and you're
like ah actually I don't know
core memory let's say you'll never ever
forget and you can always talk about it
like it's those kind of stuff that I
think that you can always look back on
and be like I'm it was maybe stupid or
maybe crazy but I'm glad I did it well
I'm sorry honestly I'm really lucky that
I did come out without a serious injury
concussions reporting that they're they
feel slower still about months after
yeah it's pretty scary that's why I
don't know if I could advise anyone to
do it really I don't think it is worth
the risk because if you brain damage
yourself get concussion I could have
written off half of this year if it had
gone really bad yeah I think a lot of
people really struggle to comprehend if
they're healthy and they're fit that
they could ever be injured severely and
have like a be punching ahead and then
you just actually just cognitively worse
offer it I think it's really hard for
people to think about that future self
of them like think about that and
they're just like it's a cool
opportunity I want to get punched it's
like well hold on now let's really let's
really look into this and see is this
actually worthwhile yeah think about the
long term like if you came out of this
yeah maybe you win it's great you got
fit you got the victory it's great for
you but like what if you you got beaten
the [__] up you have you have a
concussion that could that sticks with
you for life because when you have one
concussion you have a higher chance of
getting another concussion yeah and then
who knows what kind of damage you've
given yourself could be slower in some
ways you just don't expect could have
taken five years off your life maybe you
just don't know like what kind of dance
like that that could give you I mean the
brain is the one thing you don't want to
[__] around with yeah absolutely I have
a lot more respect for Fighters though
the discipline it takes to do all that
um you know I do have a lot of respect
for people to do it I don't know why
they do it necessarily maybe it's that
Rush there was a real rush in the ring
no I could definitely see there's like
carnal Rush yeah yeah it was pretty
[__] cool in the ring knowing all
eyes are on you for this moment what
you're about to do nothing I've never
had a feeling like that ever yeah even
being up on stage doing other things
I've never felt like that yeah that was
really good that I think is the
sensation they lock onto
yeah I mean from how you describe it it
definitely can feel like it can be an
addicting feeling
um personally I respect for you for
saying yes uh uh I don't know if I could
ever do that
I'm good I like one year ago I would
have been like no I'm not doing that I'm
just like the right set of ingredients
it took a bad Health Report it took the
objective like you know
Connor's abuse
it took like I before even just boxing
was a thing you know I was like I'm
gonna be the fittest I've ever been by
the end this year so when we brought it
up and Conor brought it up it was like
okay this is the one way to make this
happen I was just looking vicariously
through you because I wish I could do it
well you did get slapped in the face
yeah yeah but it was in there it's fire
it's you know it's not the same that was
more of like a WWE performance than yeah
it was pretty fun uh actual fine yeah I
mean it definitely hurt a little bit but
he was going easy on me and I and I was
going a little easy on him he definitely
wants you on me that's because I told
him like two minutes before I was like
by the way I've got a blood condition
don't hit me down
well because it was a slap and I knew he
wasn't we weren't trying to hurt each
other because there was no way that you
could lose via the slap right because
the idea was that it was just the chess
thing yeah uh and then give yourself a
concussion before the chess thing you
wouldn't get a concussion from being
slapped unless so they went full like
full well like like one of those like
[__] voice critical videos yeah but
that's like
they turn around to the camera and their
face is default yeah well that's that's
more than a concussion concussion is the
last thing they're worrying about in
that situation that's like playing like
[__] fear at home it's like oh am I
actually going to come out of this ring
with the same face like that's the thing
they're worrying about it just becomes
like a bowling ball yeah oh my God I've
seen some of those things yeah
and now you're fitter for it and now
you're eating now you're kind of going
back